[Applause]
have you ever noticed how badly people
behave when they're collecting their
luggage at the airport I mean they all
cluster right up against the carousel so
people behind them can't see their bags
and then when you do spot your bag you
have to push through all the other
passengers to collect it and usually
bump into them as you're grabbing your
bag off the carousel why is it that
people behave so badly it doesn't seem
to matter which airport you go to
anywhere in the world the problem is the
same and this problem believe it or not
is related to why trees are tall go with
me on this so why are trees this tall I
mean some of them are over a hundred and
fifteen meters they are the largest
organisms on the planet you might think
that they're this tall so that they can
capture sunlight and to a degree that's
true but anyone who's ever walked
through a mature forest knows that the
lower part of a tree has basically no
branches and leaves and that makes sense
because not enough light filters down
through the topmost branches to make it
worth having Sun capturing apparatus
down here over millennia trees have
evolved to put their energy where it
yields returns that is in the canopy and
not where it doesn't but this then begs
the question why put all this energy
into building a trunk that's 10 or 20
metres if you're never intending to use
this vertical space to capture sunlight
I mean it costs energy for the tree to
make this trunk plus it makes it harder
to transport water from the roots up to
the topmost branches and it makes the
tree more susceptible to water stress so
it's in every individual trees best
interest to be shorter to not have this
gigantic trunk and to use the conserved
energy to improve its seeds and its
branches to put its energy where it pays
a return but of course if there was a
mutation that allowed to treated do this
you know what would happen to it in a
forest surrounded by all these taller
trees it would be shaded from the Sun
and so it would wither and die but what
if all of the trees develop the same
mutation what if they all created a
friendship to pact
a forest of friendship in which everyone
agreed not to grow such a big trunk to
start the leaves right at the ground
well that would mean every individual
tree would be better off the trouble is
this solution is not stable because any
tiny mutation that results in a tree
that's slightly taller would advantage
that tree it would
able to capture more light and it would
shade its neighbors and so pretty soon
it would have more offspring it would
come to dominate the forest and then any
additional mutation down the line would
result in even taller trees this is how
trees got so tall I mean they would keep
getting taller until the cost of going
one more foot is exactly equal to the
benefits of collecting that additional
sunlight and that is why trees are as
tall as they are today I mean it's not
an optimal solution it's not like these
trees have the best use of their energy
but it is the one that is stable so the
point is although it's in every trees
best interest to be a part of this
forest of friendship it will never work
it'll never last because any individual
who gets a little bit taller is going to
ruin it for everyone and it's the very
same thing where you go to collect your
bags
I mean if everyone could agree to stand
a couple meters away from the carousel
everyone would have a good view of their
bags and be able to easily step forward
and collect their luggage but of course
one person standing forward is going to
block the view of people behind them so
everyone's going to rush forward it's an
unstable solution just like the forest
of friendship so remember next time you
were frustrated collecting your bags at
the airport remember trees know just how
you feel
[Music]
I'll summarize the whole problem for you
here you ready
[Music]